today on the matt walsh show is it now
officially and finally time for us to
break up do we need a national divorce
or is there another solution to the
increasing division and hostility in our
country we'll talk about that plus the
bind administration withholds
life-saving coveted treatments from red
states and the democratic gubernatorial
candidate in virginia makes the case for
executing fully developed viable infants
in the third trimester of pregnancy plus
lil nas x shares his real thoughts about
the kids that he might be influencing
and the right rallies around nicki minaj
after she comes out in support of
vaccine choice she's right about that
issue but are we a little too quick to
hail celebrities as heroes if they agree
with us about one issue we'll talk about
that and so much more today on the matt
wall show
before we get started today i have the
great privilege of telling you all about
magnesium as you know it's my favorite
topic i'm a big fan of magnesium i have
magnesium posters on my wall every day i
get home and i say to my wife guess what
i learned about magnesium today and it's
at the point now where she says you
really need to go to counseling over
this it's getting kind of strange but
still magnesium breakthrough by buy
optimizers that's what you need to know
about listen if you're having trouble
falling asleep or staying asleep one of
the best things you could possibly do is
start getting enough magnesium but
please don't run to the store to buy the
first magnesium supplement you find most
magnesium supplements
use only the two cheapest synthetic
forms and that's not gonna be good
enough for you and since they're not
full spectrum they won't fix your
magnesium deficiency to help you sleep
better there are actually seven unique
forms of magnesium and you must get all
of them if you want to experience its
calming sleep enhancing effects that's
why i recommend magnesium breakthrough
by buy optimizer simply take two
capsules before you go to bed and you'll
be amazed by how much better you sleep
and how much more rested you feel when
you wake up for an exclusive offer for
my listeners go to
www.magbreakthrough
walsh and use code walsh10 to save 10
when you try magnesium breakthrough oh
and one more thing for a limited time
buy optimizers is also giving away free
bottles
of their best-selling products p30m and
mass zymes with select purchases so go
to
magbreakthrough.com walsh now to get
your exclusive 10 discount plus the
chance to get more than 50 worth of 50
worth of supplements for free
well this is a scene that we should
expect to see repeated over and over
again in the coming months and probably
years
a family attempting to enjoy their
dinner at a new york city pizza
restaurant were kicked out for not
presenting their vaccine cards the man
filming is named ray velez and the pizza
place is apparently juliana's pizza in
brooklyn a little bit of background here
new york city just this week began
enforcing its rules requiring employees
and customers at all restaurants and
bars and gyms and museums and other
establishments to present their id and
vaccine cards upon entering um they so
they they just started enforcing in fact
when we were in new york last week we
were noticing the signs all over the
place saying that you have to have a
vaccine to enter
uh the establishment but then
i would go in and nobody would actually
ask for any kind of card uh apparently
just this week they decided to start
asking for them and that means that the
manager
you'll hear in the beginning of this
video
is only trying to comply with the
government's rules
he's following orders
and you could decide if that's a good
enough excuse for you listen
so you're refusing to service
are you refusing service
[Music]
you so you're going to enforce
segregation because we just told you
that we're religiously exempt you told
us
i never told you any of that i would
never tell you that i would never say
that
i would never say that
you're happy you don't have to leave
i if you have the flyer you have the
flyer that you're supposed to put into
your your window right
okay go and read it go and read it go
and read it and you tell me we're not
believing well i'm not leaving you guys
to leave i'm not leaving
everybody in here is okay with that
everybody's in here okay with with
setting up setting segregation in
society everybody's okay with that
oh we don't have our vaccine card so now
the kids can't eat we can't eat you guys
are okay with that this is the america
you want to live in yeah yeah is this
the america you want to live in no you
you see you're not american that's why
you need to get the [ __ ] out of here if
you're not american all right get the
[ __ ] out of here okay this is america
and in america everybody can eat
everybody can eat in america all right
this is not segregation
this is america you need to wake up this
is the kind of country you want to live
in you want to live in this type of
country
now it has not escaped the notice of
some observers that the family getting
kicked out of the restaurant is
non-white hispanic i assume based on the
name while the manager and most of the
patrons supporting the manager are all
white
in fact one of the patrons even flips
the middle finger to the family
does that make this a does that make
this this a racist incident are these
vaccine passport laws themselves racist
well the answer is no the family would
have been told to leave just the same if
they were white these laws and policies
are unjust but not racially unjust the
policies are not intended to target
non-white people clearly if anything the
racial intentions arguably might go the
other way certainly the media has
decided that the so-called anti-vaxxers
and anti-massacres are mostly white
trump supporters that's a significant
part of the reason why they wish to
target and shame those groups
with that said it's also undeniably true
that in many places around the country
the black and hispanic communities have
lower vaccination rates this means that
they will be disproportionately affected
by the vaccine passport rules and
mandates normally the left tells us that
a law's disproportionate impact on
non-white people means that the law is
racist
so once again by their own standard
yes this video depicts a racist incident
a hate crime in fact
remember also that
the entire argument for voter id laws
being racist is that black people
allegedly have a harder time getting ids
nobody's ever been able to explain why
that would be the case but that's what
they tell us
while the policy in new york requires
you to present you heard it there your
vaccine card and your id
in order to access basic public
accommodations
by the logic of the left's anti-voter id
stance this requirement is racist
all of that is true
and yet it doesn't matter because as we
have established repeatedly the left
isn't worried about its own double
standards its double standards are not
really double standards at all they are
in fact quite upfront and explicit about
this the standard is this
whatever they are doing or saying in any
given moment is rights
whatever we are doing or saying is wrong
that's the standard and it's as simple
as that
and that brings us to the most important
point raised in the video a question he
asks the other people
in the restaurant
is this the kind of country you want to
live in
you know do you want to live in a
country where we segregate people based
on vaccinated and unvaccinated do you
want to hide behind
masks and vaccine passports your whole
life
do you want to just cower in fear do you
want to live in a country governed by
fear and paranoia and suspicion
do you want to treat everybody around
you like they're a bunch of plague
carrying rats
is that the kind of country you want
and the answer that he heard there sadly
is yes
yes and fu as well as one of the other
other customers answered with his middle
finger raised
this is indeed the country they want
this is how they want to live
and that is yet one more reason why we
cannot all continue to live in the same
country for much longer
it's not just this issue of course but
this issue again reveals a truth that we
need to finally once and for all
confront there is a deep division in
this country and the people on either
side of that division
on either side of that
chasm
have radically and fundamentally
opposing desires for the sort of society
they want to live in
this goes far beyond political
differences
our visions for the future our hopes for
tomorrow stand in complete contrast with
one another such a contrast that one
side's dream for the future is the other
side's nightmare
it wasn't always this way but it is now
we have no common values no shared
principles no shared beliefs we have
nothing in common we don't like or
respect each other
a talk show host can make jokes about
trump voters dying of covet in florida
and the audience in the studio and at
home
laughs and claps joyously
about the thought of tens of thousands
of people they don't like dying
they are quite literally happy to see
the people on the other side of that
divide die
when a conservative talk show host
succumbs to covid and leaves his wife a
widow and his children fatherless
the other side now doesn't even pretend
to be sad about it
they cheer his death
they didn't know him never did anything
to them but they know his ideological
stance and that's enough
but this also isn't all about their
attitudes i mean i don't root for
anybody to die of covid but i do share
in their fundamental lack of respect for
the side opposed to my own
i admit that when i see a man who thinks
that we should force masks onto
two-year-olds you know that video we
played to start the show yesterday of a
two-year-old sitting on the plane
gasping for breath and crying confused
and scared with a with this mask on his
face
when i see that and all of these people
who support that
and many of them also support you know
chemically castrating 12 year olds and
dismembering babies in the womb
when i see a man who holds all those
views
i cannot respect him
even if i wanted to respect him i
couldn't
there's nothing to respect
it's easy enough to say that well we can
disagree but we should still respect
each other i don't
i don't want to share a country with
people like that
and they don't want to share a country
with me i know that
and increasingly people on both sides
are becoming aware of this problem in
fact the comedian sarah silverman made
much the same point on her podcast just
a few days ago from the other
side of the of the coin uh listen to
what she had to say
i mean this may be a negative thought
but or maybe a positive one i don't know
but if people aren't getting along
uh like in relationship they break up
you know so like why don't we just
finally just
realize that this
these states aren't working and like
divide up into like two or three
countries
of like usa one and usa two
and they can be usa one like the
conservatives can be usa one because
they love being number one and that it
means something to them and i'd love to
have that
be theirs they can be usa one will be
usa too
and we'll be allies
and you'll come over
here and we'll go over there and you
know when you come to certain
many times when you go to a different
country you have to get a vaccine
now um i think
we could come up with better names than
usa1 and usa too but if those were the
names
she's right that i would want to be usa1
not for the reason she says but because
usa one implies that it's the original
the first
and i actually cherish and respect this
country's founding and its history
i want to maintain a tie with it
her side doesn't that in fact is yet
another thing that makes our divide
insurmountable and it makes this uh it
uncrossable there's no bridge that can
cross it
because they hate the country they live
in they have disdain for its history
it's cultured traditions everything
i would imagine that if they had their
own country they wouldn't want usa in
the name at all
they probably want to call it the
people's republic of north america or
something
and that's fine
they can call it whatever they want
because it would be their country
silverman i think is right to compare
this to a bad marriage you know some
couples reach a point where all they do
is fight
and the fights over time grow more
vicious sometimes violent
eventually it gets dangerous for one or
both of the spouses involved they resent
each other
they the love they once shared has
turned to hate
they can't stand the sight of each other
even the things they used to like about
each other have now turned to sources of
irritation and the things that used to
merely irritate them now provoke rage
they can't stand the way the other eats
speaks smells
now the only difference is that in a
marriage you've made an eternal vow to
one another you have promised to never
leave to stay together in sickness and
health until death
that's the reason that's reason enough
just when you go through that in a
marriage but try to struggle through it
if you can go to counseling look for a
solution
but we as a nation have made no eternal
vows
we never promised to be together forever
we can't promise that
no nation
no nation on earth remains wholly intact
forever
doesn't happen nations are formed they
expand they break apart they change
eventually they cease to exist
that's the cycle of history we are not
exempt from it
and we need to realize that
probably history will look back on the
united states in its current form
as a star that shined brightly but
burned out quickly
that'll be our legacy and it's not a
terrible legacy to have
every star burns out eventually
at least hours while it lasted
was the brightest in the sky
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
if you're one of the millions of
americans male or female who deals with
bags and puffiness under the eyes then
you are disgusting and you need to get
that
taken care of that's why i want to tell
you about genusl serum from chamonix
genus cell serum uses plant stem cell
technology to promote visibly healthier
skin and the appearance of younger
healthier eyes genusel's state of the
art technology will become your most
powerful weapon against under eye bags
and puffiness
customers everywhere have been raving
about this product susan from new jersey
wrote i've been using genusel for a
couple of months the puffiness around my
eyes is gone even the crow's feet and
small lines have disappeared and haven't
come back i love your product i use it
under my eyes under my cheekbones and on
my eyelids not only that but
my assistant tessa has been using
genisell for a couple of weeks now and
loves the results that she's seeing as
well so with its instant effects you'll
you'll see results in the first 12 hours
for your money back guaranteed so order
now and save big on genusell's risk-free
introductory offer all orders are up to
fifty percent off go to geniusell.com
and enter mat30 for an extra 30 off
today that's genusell.com
genusell.com yeah i was sitting down
with my kids dinner last night and uh i
asked them as i always ask them you know
what did you learn today in their in
their home school classes
and in the past i've asked them
uh i would ask them a broader question
like what happened today or you know
what did you do today
and i realized with kids you got to be
more specific because if you ask a broad
question you know i would always ask
what happened today
and the answer would always be something
like
uh well we went outside and we saw
something in the yard and we went up to
it and it was a squirrel he was dead and
he in his his he didn't have eyes
and i would say wow
dead squirrel huh
what else happened anything no that was
it just a dead squirrel
what did you do with the dead squirrel
oh we played dodge ball with it oh dear
god
get away from you all the black plague
now um so i i get more specific and now
i ask what did you learn today and that
could be a fruitful thing so i asked
that yesterday and um my kids told me
that they were learning about one of the
one of the things they learned about
was persuasion
and uh what what is persuasion and how
do you persuade people you know
especially in the form of writing
and they were telling me about that and
i said well that's great so
let's try this out can you persuade me
of something just try to persuade me of
of something
and they couldn't figure out what they
should persuade me of and then of course
my wife was was there and she chimed in
immediately and said oh kids you should
persuade daddy to get a dog because
we're still doing the dog thing
and uh my daughter made an attempt
and her attempt at persuasion was this
daddy i am persuading you
you are being persuaded get a dog get a
dog you're persuaded
and i try to explain to her that's not
persuasion you can't just
make your demand louder and louder
but what you're doing here this is like
an exorcism the power of christ compels
you that's not persuasion
but then i also realized that um
that is basically how arguments go on
twitter this is she's she's ready for
her own twitter account i think because
that's that's the way persuasion works
not just on twitter but in society
generally
all right so let's start with this the
uh for the daily wire says the binding
administration is tightening its grip on
the distribution of coronavirus um
monoclonal antibody treatments to states
after a slew of predominantly
republican-led states in the south have
started requesting larger amounts of the
treatment to battle rising chronovirus
cases politico reported federal health
officials plan to allocate specific
amounts to each state under the new
approach in an effort to more evenly
distribute the 150 000 doses that the
government makes available each week the
approach is likely to cut into shipments
to gop-led states in the southeast that
have made the pricing antibody drug a
central part of their pandemic strategy
while simultaneously spurning mass
mandates and other restrictions
well they've made
that treatment a part of their coveted
strategy because in places like florida
especially it has cut down on
hospitalizations precipitously it is it
has made a dramatic
difference
um i want to say could be wrong off the
top of my head i want to say that in
florida it's cut hospitalizations even
in half or something close to that
so this is a drug that really works
and that's why they've
built a lot of their coronavirus
response around it why wouldn't they
it's a drug that works
now biden had said that he was going to
just a week or two ago
when he was unveiling his
big coveted strategy that's been that
you know vaccine mandates were part of
it but he also said that he was going to
increase the distribution
of this kind of treatment and instead
what we find out is that he's cutting it
and coincidentally
the states that are suffering from that
the most are the red states it just so
happens by coincidence that he's taking
this treatment away from the red states
this is
i i mean this is obviously evil
it's it's
this is not really a coincidence sarcasm
aside clearly
you've got a a treatment that works
and is working in florida and now the
bind administration says we're going to
give you less of it
why would they do that
if not because
it's more politically convenient for
them
to have more people dying in florida
the pandemic is politically convenient
for them and especially when the
pandemic
affects red states
and especially florida because they're
worried about ron desantis in 2024
so they would rather have people die
that's a simple reality of it this is
pure evil
it's one of the things that makes joe
biden so dangerous
and it's something you always have to
worry about well with any politician but
especially one who's been
hanging around dc and has been in office
positions of power
or grasping for positions of power for
40 years
uh 40 or 50 years you know that this is
someone who's just totally soulless you
can't be in office that long
and
retain your soul
if you can that's a very rare exception
joe biden is certainly not an exception
so this is a soulless man
who doesn't care if people and
especially people in florida
die now if you doubt that let's listen
to the white house responding to this
charge that they are um
[Music]
reducing the the this the distribution
of this treatment to florida well it's
not a charge it's not an allegation they
are really doing it
but here is uh jen pasaki trying to
explain why they're doing it and you
tell me if it makes sense to you listen
he promised on september 9th that he was
going to send 50 more supply of
monoclonal antibodies to states
yet the binding administration is
cutting supplies in red states by 50 50
so for example
uh you know in florida they were
expecting to get 70 000 doses this week
which they say they need they're only
getting 30 000 doses and this is not
just for unvaccinated people in south
florida half the people who are seeking
this treatment are fully vaccinated so
why is the biden administration cutting
these supplies
that's not accurate so let me give you
the accurate information uh first of all
we are increasing our distribution this
month by 50 percent in early august we
were distributing an average of a
hundred thousand doses per week now
we're shipping an average of a hundred
and fifty thousand doses per week over
the last month though uh and one thing
that i think people need to understand
for clarity facts i know i know you're
like facts um is that monoclonal
antibodies are life-saving therapies
that are used after infection to prevent
more severe outcomes so clearly the way
to protect people and save more lives is
to get them vaccinated so that they
don't get
the covet to begin with but over the
last month given the rise in cases due
to the delta variant and the lower
number of vaccination rates in some of
these states like florida like texas
just seven states are making up 70
percent of the orders our supply is not
unlimited and we believe it should be
equitable across states across the
country
a lack of supply so why cut them to
those states only if there's no
republicans i think our role as the as
the government overseeing the entire
country is to be equitable in how we
distribute we're not going to give a
greater percentage to florida over
oklahoma nor do i think are you
suggesting that
you're not going to give a greater
percentage to florida over oklahoma why
not
there's 12 people living in oklahoma
and they've all got 500 miles between
them
but we wouldn't give a greater
percentage to oklahoma than florida and
i'm sure you would never suggest that
yeah yeah any sane rational person would
in fact i think the real population is
uh it's like what two or three million
people in oklahoma versus 20 or 25
million in florida
um
yeah there's a reason to give them more
also florida is a tourist destination so
they've always got more people coming in
oklahoma
god love them no one is going
no one is using their vacation time
going to oklahoma so
um
yeah that doesn't make any sense at all
but i i like that she uses the word
equitable there
you know
because this isn't
it's not fair it doesn't make sense
it's not uh proportional
not using any words like that
but equitable rather the word is
equitable
and equitable when used by government
official always means
that we are going to arbitrarily
or based on our own political needs
point
decide who the winner and loser is going
to be that's what equitable means when
used by someone like that
it always means
equitable policy is a policy where we in
positions of power get to decide who the
winners and losers are going to be and
if you're a loser in this case it means
you die
and since we're on the subject of
governor government policies that kill
people we'll go now to
the governor's race in virginia where
terry mcauliffe
another guy who's been
sniffing in positions of power or
sniffing at power for
decades the the dude just won't go away
and now he's running for governor of
virginia again
[Music]
and they had a debate last night he was
asked about
late term abortion specifically so this
is third trimester abortion
these are babies who are
fully developed they are quote unquote
viable
meaning they could survive outside the
womb
um
how does he feel about abortion in that
case and here's what he says about it
so the issue here is in order for a
woman to get an abortion in the third
trimester you have to have a primary
doctor certified and then you have to
have two other doctors the problems you
have in rural parts of our state is
there not three doctors so that really
puts women in rural communities at a
real disadvantage so if they came up
with a solution in a woman's life has to
be in danger has to be certified if you
have a legitimate doctor that says this
woman who lives in danger of course i
would support that i'll do anything i
can and that's the difference
my opponent as you know wants to ban
abortions he has said that he got caught
secretly on tape saying i will go on
offense i will go on offense to defund
planned parenthood and ban abortions and
then he said oh but we're not going to
tell the voters about it because if they
find out the independents won't vote for
me but don't worry i won't go squish
young i can tell you this to women
watching tonight i was a brick wall
i kept our 16 women's clinics open when
i was governor of the commonwealth of
virginia and if we allow this texas law
i can tell you this amazon google
facebook thank you it's dangerous for a
woman's life but it also is crippling to
the virginia economy
these high-tech
okay so let's let's kill fully developed
infants
we know the left they when it comes to
abortion they prefer to talk about the
hard cases they prefer to talk about
you know rape and incest that's what
they want to
they want this entire discussion to be
centered around less than far less than
one percent of all abortions
uh they also prefer to talk about
abortions very early on
in pregnancy
um but
the truth is that every single one of
them
i mean anyone who is pro-abortion or
quote-unquote
pro-choice anyone who identifies
themselves in in the year 2021
as pro-choice
it means that they support abortion
through all phases of pregnancy
there are rare exceptions to that
mcauliffe certainly is not an exception
now
the way that they dress it up is this
whole bit about it's only to save the
life of the mother
you need to understand and i will and i
will continue to clarify this every
single time it comes up
that is a
a fantasy
okay
that that category of abortion does not
exist
it is never
under aligned here never necessary to
have an abortion
in the third trimester of pregnancy or
at any trimester but we're talking about
the third trimester
it is never necessary
to have a late term abortion to save the
life of a mother never
okay
there are certainly
things that can happen in a pregnancy
where a woman's
life is in jeopardy
and it means that the pregnancy has to
be ended
but there are
two ways in fact i'm like actually
there's only one way
in in the third trimester of apprentice
if you want to end a pregnancy there is
only one way to do it
and that is to deliver the baby
the question is whether you kill the
baby before delivering him
that's an extra step
there is no medical reason to do it
so if a woman has a catastrophic health
complication which certainly does happen
and the doctor says you're gonna die um
if we don't deliver this baby and the
baby will probably die too
then yeah obviously you're gonna deliver
the baby there is no reason why you have
to kill the baby first
no reason
that's an extra step if anything it's
gonna it's gonna be more dangerous for
the mother now because you're taking
this extra step
rather than simply
taking the baby out
now we should also remember that um
life of the mother i mean everything
these people say you you can't take any
word they use or any phrase they use at
face value never make the mistake of
doing that
because we know that real life of the
mother abortions never happen
and would never need to happen
so what are they actually talking about
well when you look at this is the case
in virginia uh it's you know any of
these states when you
you look at the the language and the
laws and in the policies what do you
mean by life of the mother
what you're going to find is that they
take a very expansive view
about life of the mother cases
and oftentimes you're going to find that
you know if a mother's
emotional
you know if she's being if she thinks
that having a baby would jeopardize her
emotional health or her psychological
health
or even her financial health
then that counts as a life of the of the
mother situation for an abortion
in other words
any reason
what anything could be affirmed as uh
uh as you know
a life of the mother
any reason a mother comes up with
in the third trimester to get an
abortion they can find a way to make
that a life of the mother situation
that's the reality
now so that was terry mcauliffe
let's go over to his opponent this guy
glenn younkin
and you can see if you're watching the
video here you can see terry mcauliffe
points to glenn and accuses glenn of
being wanting to ban abortion
he makes this uh this slanderous claim
that glenn thinks that we should not
kill any babies
but glenn once glenn the republican
wants to make it very clear that this is
not true and he in fact supports killing
babies in many circumstances
uh let's listen to his answer
this is an incredibly sensitive and
personal topic
and i do appreciate the fact that you
would like to write legislation with me
i think the texas bill is one that is
the standard right now that we're all
looking at
and i would not sign the texas bill
today
as i've said through this entire
campaign i'm pro-life
i believe in exceptions in the case of
rape and incest and when the life of the
mother is in jeopardy
but the texas bill also also is
unworkable and confusing
what we're not doing this evening is
talking to my opponent about his extreme
views
see my opponent doesn't want to talk
about this topic tonight because
he actually called legislation that
would enable abortion paid for with
taxpayer money all the way up through
and including birth
where a child is kept comfortable while
decision is made where that child lives
or dies he called that legislation
common sense legislation and said he
would sign it
uh
i haven't looked at the polls in
virginia i don't need to look at the
polls i can already tell you
that this joker is gonna lose and
deserves to
this brand of republicanism has been a
loser for decades
even more of a loser now
i mean it's never been appealing to
the left
it's never been appealing to the blessed
independence that you're trying to win
and more and more conservatives and
people on the right are just fed up with
it so
you're not really appealing to anyone
rather than then he's got an opportunity
here in this debate
with voters watching
to stand up there and make the case
against abortion to explain
why he is allegedly pro-life
it's not that hard to do
yeah he could say all he wants is this
is an incredibly personal
and complicated it's not complicated
it's not even personal really
it's very simple
it's not hard if you're a republican or
it shouldn't be to stand up there and
say listen
i
believe
that it is never okay to intentionally
destroy innocent human life
that's what i believe
and that principle for me holds true for
all human life at all stages of
development
that's not hard to say
it shouldn't be hard to say
and that's that is an argument that the
other that snake on the other side there
terry mcauliffe he has no response for
that what you do is you flip it around
and you say uh terry
so you believe that sometimes it can be
okay to intentionally destroy innocent
human life and then he's gonna say oh no
that's not what i'm saying okay well
then explain to me
the baby in the womb
is that is it not a human
is it not a member of the human species
what species is it
what is it an aardvark
what it would i mean what is an octopus
what if it's not a human then what is it
well of course it's a human okay is it
not living
if it's not living then why do we need
the abortion to kill it
oh so so it is a human life and so you
do think that it's okay some sometimes
to intentionally destroy innocent life
that's your position that's not mine
that shouldn't be hard to do glenn
but instead he immediately goes on the
defensive and says whoa yeah i mean i'm
pro-life but uh but i still think that
that weak there's pl look listen guys
there's plenty of babies we could still
kill okay i'm on board with killed a lot
of different babies
it's it's my opponent he's the extreme
one
let's talk about his extremism
somebody gives a damn about extremism
you call someone does this extreme i
wish you were extreme that's what we
want you should be extremely pro-life
stand up there and say yeah i'm an
extreme i am an extremist i am extremely
pro-life
he's an extremist he's extremely
anti-life so you voters have a choice do
you want someone who's extremely
pro-life or extremely anti-life
this uh
spineless
jellyfish routine it just it's it's not
gonna cut it anymore it has never cut it
it's never been a winner
republicans were able to get away with
it at least for a time and and sometimes
win elected office playing that with
that routine
not anymore
there's there's no appetite for it
all right let's go next to
uh what do we got well i gotta this is
just a follow-up from
this is my i told you so moment here
it's from the daily wire
it says you can lead audiences to a
half-dressed aging pop star but you
can't make them watch
uh nice line there who wrote this
megan basham wrote that so billy wire
nice line um that's the uh the lesson
mtv has to be taking from this year's
video music awards which clocked their
lowest ratings on record despite a
surprise appearance from madonna wearing
a one-piece leather thong
and fishnet stockings um the six
three-year-old fellow celebrities
showered her with accolades for the
cameo but the ratings were really low so
what is the um
what were the ratings for the vmas it
says traditional ratings however leave
no doubt that viewership for the vmas
once again hit bottom
drawing only 900 000 viewers for the
live run of the show
it marked the first time in mtv's
history that fewer than one million
people tuned in to its flagship awards
program for comparison the vmas drew
nearly 10 million viewers in 2015 and
more than 11 million in 2010.
now i can remember when i was a teenager
and um the vmas were
they were a cultural event and it felt
like everybody was watching them and
everybody was talking about them the
next day
um and that's not the case less fewer
than a million people tuned in for the
vmas
and that only supports my point that i
started with
on monday
that
you know
the the
the degeneracy and filth and perversion
all of these
things that these desperate pop stars do
to be shocking
it doesn't it's it's boring now
because we live in a culture where this
is mainstream i mean you could it used
to be
you would if you if you you would turn
on the vmas
and you would see things that counted as
legitimately sort of edgy
and you might see crazy things happen on
the vmas that you wouldn't find
elsewhere
now unfortunately whatever you find on
the vmas
you find that anywhere
all over the place
um and what that means is it's just dull
and boring and
nobody cares
even the people who agree with it still
don't really care
uh here's a guy who tries desperately to
be shocking lil na's ex
he appeared on the breakfast club radio
show
and um one question that he gets a lot
and for good reason is
what about the what about the kids uh
and the reason why he gets this question
is because he's he started with that
terrible song old town road
which was an awful song a really stupid
song it was
i can't even say that it was a that it
was a
i'm saying it's awful and stupid as a
song but it was also inappropriate for
kids if you look at the lyrics but
mainly was just a really dumb song
but
kids loved it and he he very
intentionally marketed to kids he went
to elementary schools and middle schools
and performed he performed on
nickelodeon and all these things and he
garnered this intentionally garnered
this audience of young children
and then did a bait and switch
and started putting out graphic
satanic literally satanic music
and um he was asked asked about that on
the breakfast club morning show here's
his answer
parents would be like you know you have
a responsibility because kids are
watching you hear that cardi b had that
same problem and nikki had that same
problem do you feel that same way like
how does your own kids i feel like i
used to but now just like
a soul
like like [ __ ] your kids not like your
kids that's exactly what you just said
okay what agenda is that the kid's
agenda
it's like um
we really get one one chance to do this
at least to my knowledge i don't know
like what happens when we die or not uh
so it's like i'm not
i'm not like about to pender to your
kids or you
like anybody like even i have even have
to do this with my family members you
know like because my family members may
not always agree with what i'm doing or
like whoever i'm dating like they may
not agree but it's like
i honestly really truly want to live by
you know this is our life we get to do
this so
what anybody else has to really say
about it i guess you know i would say
when it comes to the music just tell
people that's the reason there's a
parental advisory sticker that too on on
the music did you see the youtube kids
thing you know i don't know if you saw
that
it was like a lady she's like she like
searched up
music for babies oh i saw that and they
said something like that like industry
baby popped up and she was like
surprised like you looked up baby and
music and music like what do you what do
you expect from that
yeah like uh like
like i'm gonna do what i want like and
that's like what i'm just gonna do is
what i want and like that's how i'm
gonna live like
what does it say about our culture that
this guy with an iq of 42.
i mean i've i've had
caesar salads at applebee's that had a
higher iq than this guy and he's a
he's a big star and how do you get a big
start it's just like he wears dresses
and walks around in dresses and everyone
goes well it's revolutionary he's a
brilliant artist
ever every male artist is wearing
dresses now
there's either who is it i think it's
russell westbrook
nba stars are now walking around in
dresses
they still want to convince us that this
is
some sort of brilliant
boundary breaking thing
but his answer
so far as it could be
translated and understood was f your
kids
and that's how he feels about it
um
these people are all
speaking of soulless they're all
soulless sociopaths
and uh they they just simply don't care
they do not care about your kids
they feel no responsibility at all
to anyone but themselves they they are
this is why
it is so appropriate that um he put out
that satanic video where he's you know
uh twerking on satan's lap
because although he meant it to be
partly satirical or
however he would justify it
he is a satanist and that he belongs in
the religion of himself he is a
self-worshiper and
he said it there
very clearly nothing else in the world
matters nobody else matters only me
all right finally i got to play this
before we get to reading the youtube
comments um
here's some important footage
this is from
i think this is in brooklyn okay let's
play the footage here there's a guy at a
stoplight
and uh
something the truck behind him does that
thing go ahead and play
the truck behind him does that thing
where as soon as the light turns green
he lays on the horn go and so
the dude in the car just got honked at
he gets out
and starts dancing in the street
that's his way of responding
to the guy
this is not bad dance moves considering
there's no music
and so this is this is his response you
know what now i would not personally
respond that way to being honked at
when i'm at the light
because of my policy of never dancing in
front of anybody or never dancing in
general
but i'm i'm fully on his side i'm on the
dancing guys side here normally you know
this is my first time usually you're
dancing in the street holding up traffic
i'm not going to be outside but this is
an impo this is an important point that
he's making i think he's taking an
important stand here
because that annoys me to no end
okay what is he doing now all right
we're getting a little bit graphic there
um it annoys me to know when you're at
the light and the the light you're
waiting and the light turns green
and
half a second later someone behind you
is laying on the horn can you give me a
second to move my foot i'm just trying
to move my foot from the brake to the to
the gas i'm not on my phone okay don't
worry about it
can you just get i i know you're sitting
there at the light
just
anxious to get but i'm i'm uh i just
have my foot on the brake i all i need
to do you need to give me you know what
i need i need three quarters not half a
second give me three quarters of a
second to move my foot from the break to
the gas can you do that
what are you in such a hurry for like
you got nothing going on in your life
you're not as important as you're
pretending to be
all these people in a hurry so that you
can get home and sit on your ass and
watch netflix that's all you're gonna do
you're gonna get home and you're just
gonna sit on your tv
hurry up i gotta get home
so i can sit and do nothing for the next
seven and a half hours
and the other thing is you would never
do that
in person
and i don't like it when people get big
and tough in their cars in traffic
or online it's all the same people
when they would never do it in person if
if we were
standing in the line at airport security
and the line moved and i was just like a
half a second behind in moving my feet
to keep up with the line you would not
stand behind me and shout go
hey go you would never do that
you know you wouldn't do it you only do
it in the car
you coward
all right
gotta get that off my chest let's get
now to
reading the youtube comments
[Music]
who makes a twitter mob fly off the
handle with rage
who's to blame
it's a sweet baby gang
who's rocking polka dot and flannel
shirts without shame
do you know their name
they're the sweet baby gang
baby gang
this theocratic
dictatorship is on its way daily
cancellations
[Music]
dictatorship is on its way daily
cancellations
[Music]
you know we probably shouldn't play the
whole thing on second thought
that'll get old after a while
mainly i just want the end where they're
saying all hail matt walls that's that's
the most important part of that whole
song
all right uh let's see richard says matt
has been waiting to be confronted about
being maskless
outstanding me too
uh yeah i would like to see
even if i'm not confronted just see one
of these
viral videos going down in person
so that i could have my say about it but
as i said i have been confronted
several times maybe three times two or
three times at least about not wearing a
mask but
it never gets that far
um because the people always back down
and i think it's because i'm i'm not a
woman they're looking for women
alone at the grocery store these
predators
looking for women that they can release
this rage onto
um
the closest thing i came to was what i
uh the story that i told a couple months
ago a few months ago
at a hotel um
and uh i got into the i got into the
elevator and i didn't have a mask on
and there was you know a couple there
and the guy was had a mask he said why
don't you put your mask on
and i said no why not
and he was demanding that i get off the
elevator and it's like i'm not getting
off the elevator you can get off and
then he stormed off the elevator and
that's as far as it went
um
because again they're not they're not
looking for guys like me to pick on
they're looking for
you know
like any bully they're looking for
people smaller than them
all right
non-compliance says the video of the
baby immediately filled me with so much
rage and literally brought tears to my
eyes we are sick our society is sick and
we do not deserve a place on this earth
if that is how we treat our most
innocent and precious lives dear god
great description matt it is cruel and
barbaric i am so disgusted with humans
at this point
well i am too but it's not
that we're all flawed people we're all
flawed as members of the human race but
you know and you're using the word we
and i know you mean it in this kind of
general universal sense but
it's not really we is it
this goes back to what we talked about
at the start of the show
there's a certain portion of the
american population
that does this to kids that wants to see
it done to kids
and i feel about those people just as
you do
another reason why it's hard to see how
we can all
stay together in this uh loveless
marriage at this point
greg says i feel for you matt at some
point talking about these things is
going to give you health problems i
appreciate the commentary and candor
however aaron says i finally found
someone who shares my opinion on
conservation i've often stated
that i don't care if gorillas go extinct
because i don't eat gorillas and usually
people are pretty horrified when i say
that for some reason i'm with you on
that
you know my stance on animal rights is
that i just don't okay i don't care at
all
uh i should probably care a little bit
more than i do
and i'll admit that but on the panda
thing which is what you're referring
back to
i stand by it 100 and i have been
leading the charge against pandas
for years now i think it's one of the
most important issues that i've talked
about i should probably talk about it
more
and i'll tell you that uh the panda
topic i was very pleased to see is the
one that our friends at media matters
decided to clip yesterday
so they put they they put that uh
that clip out where i'm talking about
how pandas shouldn't exist
and you know there was a little bit of
outrage but but but i i think it sparked
a necessary conversation and i found
because they put that clip out there and
gave me an excuse to talk about it
further
there are more people in my camp
the anti-panda camp is larger than i
thought we are the silent majority
and so it's good to be able to connect
with some people
some fellow members of the anti-panda
community
because we i've had enough of this
these fat lazy good-for-nothing
things i mean they don't blend into
their environment they have no they have
no defensive skills whatsoever
they're not mating i mean science here's
what scientists are doing this is real
they're going into the forests in asia
and they're setting up like candlelight
dinners and they're playing marvin gaye
just to try to get pandas
you know to
to feel a little romantic with one
another
and it's not working because the pandas
are saying
pandas don't even like other they're not
even attracted to other pandas
the male pandas are looking at the
female pandas and saying i want nothing
to do with that look at this
just let us die off we're useless will
you let us die
and the scientists say no we need to
keep you around
so that we can have you at zoos and
little four-year-old girls can go and
say look at the cute pandas
there are other cute animals we don't
need these
all right queen persephone says i
believe that income tax is theft but
certainly you should be taxed on items
that you pay for like food cars homes
etc
um
yeah that's the consumption tax versus
the income tax
and uh
if we were capable of having any
intelligent and useful conversations in
this country whatsoever then this is
something we maybe could talk about
and instead of talking about how high
should the taxes be
how about what what should our tax
system actually be
right now we are taxed
simply for making an income the act of
earning an income means that you owe a
tax and it wasn't always that way
um
the income tax itself was supposed to be
temporary the withholding system was
supposed to be temporary and nothing
ever is temporary with the government so
that's something that we could talk
about but of course we can't talk about
it because
we can't have any discussion in this
country
except the discussion about candace
pandas rather joe biden has made one
thing incredibly clear he's going full
authoritarian and his vaccine mandate is
just the beginning last thursday he
announced his plan to mandate vaccines
for all companies with over 100
employees or test them for covet at
least once a week the daily wire has
over 100 employees ourselves uh 100 i
don't know why i pronounced it that way
we got 100 employees and we refused to
subject them to this violation of their
personal medical freedom for this daily
wire could face up to fourteen thousand
dollars for each violation and i can't
think of a better reason to let the
fines pile up then for opposing medical
tyranny and the erasure of freedom
that's why we're calling on all who are
listening uh to help daily wire fight
this obscene and tyrannical mandate if
you join us as a daily wire member right
now you'll be supplying the resources
needed to take this all the way to the
supreme court so go to dailywire.com
subscribe and use code do not comply at
checkout for 25
off
big news
daily wires starting an official
e-commerce division of our company and
we're now searching for a vice president
of e-commerce to join our team in
nashville tennessee
in this exceptional leadership
opportunity you will oversee the daily
wire division that birthed the legendary
leftist tears tumbler and even more
legendary sweet baby gang t-shirts using
your autonomy and e-commerce expertise
you and your team will be forced
will be forced you'll be forced to do
many things that you don't want to do no
you'll you will be the force behind
daily wire's e-commerce presence and the
consumer experience expressing the full
creativity wit and wisdom that
encompasses the daily wire brand if you
think you've got what it takes to be the
newest critical addition to the daily
wire leadership team and to promulgate
the mission of the daily wire brand
through e-commerce then we want to hear
from you for full details on the
responsibilities and requirements of
this position and to apply please please
visit dailywire.com careers our full
list of current openings on the daily
wire team can be found there as well
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
so i have not to this point mentioned
anything about the nicki minaj saga on
this show that's mostly because
i've been too busy talking about pandas
but also because the whole thing is
incredibly stupid but then i realized
speaking of the pandas that i talk about
incredibly stupid things on this show
all the time so why should i
discriminate in this case so to review
nicki minaj the female rapper made the
news earlier this week when she chose
not to attend the met gala because of
its vaccine requirements in explaining
her decision the following day she
tweeted
about the vaccine's alleged effects on
her cousin's friend's testicles she
wrote
my cousin in trinidad won't get the
vaccine because his friend got it and
became impotent his testicles became
swollen his friend was weeks away from
getting married now the girl called off
the wedding so just pray on it and make
sure you're comfortable with your
decision not bullied now to me the
biggest issue here is that her cousin's
friend's fiance is apparently rather
cruel and shallow
calling off the wedding because you're
betrothed has swollen testicles
just seems pretty harsh to me
just think about how the guy feels now
first his testicles swell up like
balloons the next thing you know he's
getting dumped
a very unfortunate chain of events no
doubt
now i have no idea
if this anecdotal story is true or not
um
i'm a little skeptical i i haven't heard
of that uh
side effect anywhere else but um
it doesn't matter to me with all with
all due respect to the cousin's friend
and his testicles you know whether or
not that story is true is not really the
point the important thing
in menage's statement if there is one is
that you should decide for yourself
whether you get the vaccine or not make
your own decision don't do anything
because you feel pressured into it
don't inject something into your body
because you feel pressured into it and
on that score i totally agree and i
commend her for saying it the next day
tucker carlson offered his own con
commendation on exactly that point
congratulated her for making this point
and nicki minaj then retweeted that clip
expressing approval of tucker carlson's
approval of her and that's when the left
was sent into a full-on conniption fit
first nicki minaj dared to encourage
critical thinking and then she gave a
thumbs up to that dastardly old nazi
tucker carlson
that's too much and this has led to
condemnation from all across the left
and the media as you might expect
and if you're perceptive
you also expect the next part of this
story
the right has rallied around nicki minaj
prominent conservatives and many others
on social media have called her a hero
using that exact word she's a hero
they're extolling her courage
she's being elevated as a great champion
of our cause as
conservatives i've seen well-known
conservatives urging other conservatives
to listen to uh minaj's music including
her 2014 song anaconda where she spends
three and a half minutes rapping about
penises
because they say it's a celebration of
free speech
this is a long-standing problem in
conservatism
some of us are evidently so desperate
for approval from mainstream society
that we simply can't handle it when a
celebrity agrees with us about anything
we latch on to them like groupies tears
of joy in our eyes we start forming
petitions to award them the medal of
freedom
i've seen this process play out time and
time again
and it always comes back to bite us
because although the celebrity may
happen to line up with us on one issue
they are still fundamentally opposed to
us on everything else
so the alignment is incidental and
temporary and it won't last
and there will come a time very soon
when nicki minaj says something and all
these same conservatives say well i
can't believe it she's turned her back
on us
no she didn't turn her back on you she
was never on your side
nicki minaj specifically is a purveyor
of absolute filth and stupidity her
music is gratuitous trash
she's also married to a sex offender for
the record
and
also for the record her brother is a
child rapist now that isn't her fault
but it is kind of strange that she finds
herself surrounded by
these kinds of people minaj is a big
supporter of blm she's pro-abortion so
on and so on this isn't about me being
ideologically uh pure okay the fact is
that nicki minaj is again
totally opposed to everything we stand
for
and has worked through her career to
make our culture dumber and more morally
debased
and to pollute the minds and souls of
children
all of that remains the case even if she
doesn't like vaccines
that doesn't mean that we should reject
her advocacy for vaccine choice it just
means that we should show a little
restraint
and discernment
the appropriate response to nicki minaj
is yes i agree with you on this issue
thanks for speaking out
and then we move on
we don't need to throw her a parade and
build a monument in her honor
that's all i'm trying to say
and so today unfortunately
the conservatives who've suddenly become
groupies for nicki minaj are i'm sad to
say
canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pavel vadasky
the show is edited by ali hinkle
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
makeup is done by cherokee heart and our
production coordinator is mckenna waters
the matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin